étienne decroly bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
avant de se focaliser sur la question du
vaccin contre la grippe saisonnière peut
être votre réaction à chaud après l'
alerte du président du conseil
scientifique il dit que le gouvernement
va devoir prendre des décisions
difficiles dans les prochains jours
qu'est ce que vous comprenez quel type
de décisions pourraient être prises
oui je crois qu'on voit tu as fait
clairement actuellement que l'épidémie
est hors de contrôle en france en
bâtiment dans certaines régions on a des
alertes également avec la reprise de la
surcharge dans un les hôpitaux
particulièrement par exemple autour de
marseille où la plupart des hôpitaux
covit sont maintenant à plein donc on
peut comprendre également que dans ce
contexte il faut prendre des décisions
rapides de manière à juguler la
poursuite de la progression de
l'épidémie
donc je vais attendre évidemment à ce
que l'édition du type d confinant
partiel ou éventuellement un changement
de stratégie en ce qui concerne la
politique de confinement des gens qui
ont été en contact avec des gens qui
étaient affectés soit annoncée alors
pour lutter efficacement contre la
propagation du cauvel ducobu 19 on le
disait le gouvernement a donc la volonté
d'élargir la vaccination contre la
grippe saisonnière est ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie pour vous alors ces
stratégies ne va évidemment pas modifié
la pénétration du comique 19dans dans la
population enfin du virus par contre la
difficulté évidemment c'est que on sait
que les virus de la grippe est un virus
saisonnier et qui fait d épidémie
importante en général au cours de
l'hiver et ses épidémies au cours de
l'hiver ont tendance à surcharger les
services hospitaliers
donc la stratégie ci est d'éviter de
devoir gérer deux épidémies en même
temps et qu on a actuellement un vaccin
qui est disponible contre la grippe
alors que le vaccin contre le courant
2012 n'est pas disponible on voit les
discuter du développement de ce vaccin
actuellement notamment avec l'arrêt de
certains essais cliniques contre les
vaccins contre le corona dieuze et donc
on comprend évidemment que en second
recours on veut vacciner davantage des
populations contre la grippe de manière
à éviter que les patients de l'époque
engorgent le système de soins de manière
à conserver des vies disponible pour les
gens qui seraient infectés par le sas
coronavirus alors quelles sont les
personnes particulièrement visé
particulièrement concerné 1 par
l'élargissement de la campagne de
vaccination alors vaccination contre la
grippe
on sait très bien que que la grippe est
particulièrement importante en termes de
pathologies et et d'envoi de gens
finalement à l'hôpital chez les gens qui
sont plus âgés ou qui déjà ont d autres
pathologies respiratoires et donc il
faut véritablement suit les indications
des médecins en ce qui concerne les
priorités à ce sujet parce que c'est un
fait rare la grippe saisonnière amène
beaucoup de malades ou aux urgences a
été le cas les dernières années alors
oui on sait très bien que 7000 des
maladies pour lesquelles il ya des pics
de deux fréquences à toute tentation aux
urgences et donc l'idée est évidemment
en utilisant ce vaccin des pouvoirs
limités
la fréquentation des gens qui sont des
pauvres dans les services de soins
alors est-ce qu'il faut savoir que je
vous en prie également la politique
consiste à porter davantage de masques
etc va jouer un rôle positif dans le
meilleur contrôle de l'infection par le
virus de la grippe parce qu'il est
également contrôlé au volant par la
politique de contrôle qui met en place
pour l'économie alors pour conclure
c'est vrai qu'on entend régulièrement à
des sceptiques du vaccin de vaccins en
général d'ailleurs qu'elle recule on a
concernant le vaccin contre la grippe
saisonnière aujourd'hui alors on a un
bon recul la difficulté c'est que c'est
un vaccin malheureusement qui a piqué
limitée dans le temps c'est à dire que
c'est un mac sans doute annuel parce que
chaque année de la grippe évolue parce
que limitée dans la population est venu
donc va sélectionner de nouvelles
souches boguey
qui sont mal contrôlée par les vaccins
des années précédentes et par l'unité
des années précédentes
donc c'est pour ça que c'est un vaccin
annuel est donc ça c'est une difficulté
évidemment importante c'est que un bon
chasseur on s'attend à voir une
protection sur une longue période qu'un
an et pour l'instant malheureusement on
n'est pas en capacité avec la les
risques d'avoir des vaccins qui vont
faire d imiter protective sur le long
terme alors que d'autres vaccins sont
tout à fait capables d'élever une
protection sur le long terme comme les
vaccin rougeole par exemple qui sont d
excellents médecins et protège sur des
très très longue période des personnes
qui étaient la chine
merci beaucoup etienne decroly pour
votre éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de recherche cnrs et
virologue